hey guys it is the 11th of May today my
name is Jess McDonald and your change
into games but nice the xbox one may
system update is out now and here's what
you'll get from it microsoft released
the update today which adds a voice
messaging feature further SmartGlass
functionality and additional power
saving options the voice messages can be
accessed through the consoles
pre-existing messaging app and they can
be served between xbox one and xbox 360
you'll also be able to turn your console
on and off via the smart glass app and
as Microsoft had already announced new
users will be able to choose between
instant on and energy saving modes when
they set up their console finally
Microsoft is beginning to roll out
dedicated servers for party chat The
Witcher 3 has exceeded 1 million
pre-orders just a week before its
release said abreact announced today
that the game has eclipsed 21 million
pre-orders but did not specify how that
broke down across platforms or digital
versus physical copies the game is
already on shelves in the United Arab
Emirates even though it's not you out
until May 19 although early gameplay
from The Witcher 3 has been appearing on
Twitch the sides have been quick to
snatch those streams and take them
offline until the game launches
according to a new report a full hour
for cinematic trailer is on its way and
that probably means fallout 4 is also on
its way the trailer was also produced by
guillermo del toro's production company
has spotted by video gamer the report
comes as a result of an online resume
which sites contracted work on the
project at mirada studios a production
company formed by director Guillermo del
Toro of pan's labyrinth and PT Fame
fallout 4 has not been officially
announced by Bethesda but the company
are planning their own press briefing at
e3 this year so we're expecting quite a
few meeting announcements then
let me know if you think that those are
going to announce fallout 4 at e3 this
year and are you excited by the idea
you're going to gamespot all we've got
stories on a questionable Metal Gear
Solid figurine and detailed on
Nintendo's and X systems that is it from
me today let me know what you care about
and I'll see you same time tomorrow